mutmaßliche anschlag in berlin ein mann
rennt auf der stadtautobahn andere
fahrzeuge und verletzt sechs menschen
die ermittler haben anzeichen für einen
islamistischen hintergrund europäischer
druck auf machthaber lukaschenko die eu
wird das wahlergebnis in belarus nicht
anerkennen
unklare lage nach dem putsch in mali das
militär will eine übergangsregierung
einsetzen
deutsche soldaten im land verstärkten
ihre sicherheitsvorkehrungen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers ich begrüße sie
herzlich guten abend in allen sport in
der sendung nachher mit kristin otto
wir beginnen mit dem was die ermittler
in berlin einen anschlag nennen
möglicherweise mit islamistischem
hintergrund auf einer der
meistbefahrenen autobahnen deutschlands
hat ein autofahrer nach angaben der
staatsanwälte gezielt jagd auf
motorräder gemacht die tat passierte
gestern abend auf diesem abschnitt der
berliner stadtautobahn mutmaßlicher
täter ein 30 jähriger iraker der an drei
stellen mehrere kollisionen offenbar
absichtlich verursacht hat bis er von
der polizei gestoppt wurde
es gibt sechs verletzte drei davon sind
schwer verletzt
henriette de maizière und carsten
behrendt fest verteilt lässt das
motorrad unter dem täterfahrzeug erahnen
mit welcher wucht die maschine gestern
abend getroffen wurde
drei motorradfahrer werden bei den
attacken schwer verletzt eines der opfer
liegt mit schwersten kopf- und
rückenverletzungen im krankenhaus die
kollisionen sind nach unserer
derzeitigen bewertung nicht als unfälle
zu bewerten sondern als gezielte
angriffe als anschläge auf die anderen
verkehrsteilnehmer
nachdem das fahrzeug stoppte stellte der
fahrer eine metallkiste auf sein auto
und drohte auf arabisch alle würden
sterben ein arabisch sprechender
polizist griff ein konnte den mit einem
messer bewaffneten mann festnehmen
in der kiste fand die polizei harmloses
werkzeug statt sprengstoff die
äußerungen am tatort jedoch
anhaltspunkte für ein islamistisches
motiv er soll sich entsprechend vor ort
geäußert haben dass sein verhalten und
entsprechende allahu akhbar äußerungen
haben sich ganz konkrete hinweise darauf
ergeben dass hier ein religiös ist der
mister hintergrund zugrunde liegen
könnte der mutmaßliche täter war polizei
bekannt aber nicht vorbestraft
laut staatsanwaltschaft sei er psychisch
auffällig gewesen gestern postete er auf
facebook fotos von sich und seinem auto
ohne konkreten anschlags bezug bislang
sei er nicht wegen islamismus
aufgefallen
hatte aber wohl kontakt zu einem
polizeibekannten gefährder ganz klar
dass berlin im fokus von terroristen
steht egal ob das netzwerke sind die das
planen oder ob das relativ spontane
taten sind nach dem anschlag auf der
autobahn laufen nun ermittlungen wegen
mehrfachen versuchten mordes
unser nächstes thema heute abend ein
staatschef der seit 26 jahren an der
macht ist und sich als frisch
wiedergewählt präsentiert während
hunderttausende in seinem land auf der
straße sind und wahlfälschung anprangern
das ist die lage in belarus ein
europäisches land und für die
europäische union stellt sich heute die
frage wie reagieren
in einem gipfel per video konferenz
beschlossen die staats und
regierungschefs der eu
wir erkennen das wahlergebnis in belarus
nicht an
wir fordern gespräche zwischen führung
und opposition
und niemand soll sich von außen
einmischen weder russland noch die eu
was das vor ort bedeutet zeigt christian
sie in minsk versucht die polizei die
proteste zu zerstreuen und präsident
lukaschenko droht wieder den
demonstranten aber das innenministerium
aufgefordert die proteste zu beenden
wenn jemand glaubt dass die macht hier
ins wanken geraten ist der täuscht sich
lukaschenko gibt nicht auf europa will
den demonstranten helfen was erwarten
sie
ich erwarte nichts vom westen ich denke
nicht dass sie uns irgendwie wesentlich
helfen können ich bin der meinung das
belarussische volk muss das selbst
schaffen
vom main geht's retten sie uns helfen
sie uns wir appellieren an die ganze
welt
die unternehmen alles mögliche um
irgendeine freiheit zu erreichen um zu
erreichen dass wir gehört werden
auf friedliche art und weise wir wollen
auch keine aggression antworten die
selbsterklärte wahl siegerin swetlana
tier an oskar wendete sich heute direkt
an europas politiker ein appell diese
betrügerische wahl wie sie sagt nicht
anzuecken
die staats und regierungschefs der eu
treffen sich heute zur video konferenz
um über belarus zu beraten
die eu erkennt die von wahlfälschung
überschattete wahl nicht an
und kanzlerin merkel betont die
unabhängigkeit von belarus
wir setzen uns ein für einen nationalen
dialog wäre ja auch von der opposition
in belarus vorgeschlagen wird und das
muss ein inklusiver dialog sein an dem
auch alle beteiligt sein können
weißrussland muss seinen weg für sich
alleine finden
es muss über dialog gehen innerhalb des
landes und es darf keine einmischung von
außen geben und in belarus gehen sie
weiter auf die straße damit lukaschenko
zurücktritt und der weg frei ist für
neue wahlen und guten abend jetzt an
unsere korrespondenten in brüssel und in
moskau zunächst alle in brüssel wie sehr
hat denn die eu bei ihrer reaktion jetzt
auch eine mögliche reaktion aus russland
mit dem blick die frage wie russland auf
den machtverlust von lukaschenko in
belarus reagiert ist natürlich auf
diesem gipfel mit gedacht worden
und so erklärt sich auch der balance akt
den die staats und regierungschefs heute
vollführt haben einerseits starke
unterstützung für die belarussische
opposition die ja für rein europäische
werte auf der straße steht wie
demokratie freie wahlen freie
meinungsäußerung andererseits haben die
staats und regierungschefs peinlichst
versucht den eindruck zu vermeiden dass
sich die eu in will in belarus
einmischen könnte um eben keinen vorwand
zu liefern für andere länder wie
russland das gleiche zu tun die spitzen
der eu haben mantraartig heute
wiederholt dass das bilder russische
volk seinen weg selbst wählen müsste
gleichzeitig versucht man aber den
gesprächsfaden mit dem kreml aufrecht zu
erhalten der franzose makro kanzlerin
merkel und eu chefs eu gipfelchef
michelle haben mit putin in den letzten
tagen telefoniert um ihm klar zu machen
wie hoch die politischen kosten eines
militärischen eingreifens russlands in
belarus wohl sein würden und immerhin
putin redet noch mit den europäern
lukaschenko das erzählte merkel heute
auf ihr
pressekonferenz hat es abgelehnt mit der
kanzlerin zu telefonieren und christian
wie sieht denn die opposition in belarus
das ganze sehen die sich jetzt als
prowestlich oder als anti russisch
alexander lukaschenko oder lässt er
keine gelegenheit aus die opposition zu
diskreditieren
er hat auch behauptet die opposition sei
anti russisch unterwegs das stimmt aber
überhaupt nicht die menschen die auf die
straße gehen sie sind weder prowestlich
noch antirussische stehen geht es vor
allem darum dass lukaschenko zurücktritt
und dass dann der weg frei ist wenn neue
und faire wahlen ein
oppositionspolitiker hat es auch nochmal
ganz klar betont und hat gesagt das
letzte was ein politiker in belarus
jetzt machen würde wäre eine mauer
zwischen belarus und russland aufzubauen
weil die wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit
von belarus die ist doch einfach riesig
herzlichen dank nach moskau und nach
brüssel
und jetzt in der sendung der blick auf
die korona zahlen eine weitere
verschärfung der situation muss
unbedingt verhindert werden warnt das
robert koch institut die zahlen steigen
nämlich weiter so gab es innerhalb eines
tages 1510 neue registrierte fälle der
höchste wert seit mai und dem
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 1230 menschen neu angesteckt
gestern waren es noch 1170 über die
gründe und hintergründe berichtet anselm
stern üben auf der intensivstation in
der uniklinik in kiel trainieren ärzte
und pflegekräfte die abläufe was zu tun
ist wenn hier ein echter corona patient
liegt aktuell sind nicht nur hier in
schleswig holstein viele betten frei
doch die fallzahlen in deutschland
wachsen weiter und mit ihnen die sorgen
natürlich schon in gespannter erwartung
auf das was jetzt möglicherweise im
herbst wenn es kälter draußen kommen
könnte insbesondere dann wenn wir wieder
auf die nächste influenza saison
zusteuert grippewelle plus corona keine
guten aussichten die gegenwart in diesem
sommer sieht so
immer mehr urlaubsrückkehrer bringen das
virus mit fast 40 prozent aller neu
infizierten stecken sich mittlerweile im
ausland an
die meisten auf dem balkan aber auch in
der türkei oder in spanien
das erinnert an so ein bisschen in die
situation im märz wo die skifahrer alle
zurückkamen und uns die infektion
mitgebracht haben und das macht dann
natürlich schon gedanken nach dem urlaub
kommt jetzt das stäbchen es wird mehr
getestet natürlich ist das auch ein
grund für steigende fallzahlen aber die
gut 670.000 registrierten tests pro
woche in deutschland sind nur ein grober
überblick denn hier sind mehrfach
testungen dabei außerdem melden nicht
immer alle labore ihre daten die zahl
der tests sagt also nur wenig über den
tatsächlichen stand der krise das heißt
für den anstieg im moment kann ich die
vermehrte testung verantwortlich gemacht
werden verantwortlich für den anti virus
kampf ist auch er jens spahn gerade eben
im uniklinikum kiel die steigenden
fallzahlen seien besorgniserregend so
der gesundheitsminister
alarmstimmung aber sei nicht angebracht
um in der korona zwei jobs zu retten
schlägt die ig metall eine vier tage
woche vor
weniger arbeiten bei teilweisem
lohnausgleich das kann sich jetzt auch
arbeitsminister hubertus heil spd
vorstellen um gemeinsam durch die krise
zu kommen
skeptischer sind die arbeitgeber und der
cdu-wirtschaftsrat winkt ab dadurch
würden die lohnkosten nach oben
getrieben
bereits auf den weg gebracht hat die
bundesregierung das hartz4 empfänger ab
dem kommenden jahr mehr geld bekommen
der regelsatz für alleinstehende
erwachsene steigt um 7 euro auf 439 euro
im monat
den größten sprung gibt es für
jugendliche zwischen 14 und 17 39 euro
mehr im monat insgesamt 367 euro
ebenfalls im kabinett heute
der klimaschutzbericht für 2009/10 und
da hat deutschland weniger treibhausgase
ausgestoßen - 6,3 prozent gegenüber 2008
angesichts der korona krise könnte es
für die klimaziele in diesem jahr dann
doch noch reichen
der militärputsch in mali bereitet auch
in berlin kopfzerbrechen denn im moment
sind dort über 900 bundeswehrsoldaten im
rahmen einer uno und einer eu mission im
einsatz
die aufständischen militärs beeilen sich
zwar bald neuwahlen zu versprechen und
den übergang zu einer zivilen regierung
die lage ist aber unübersichtlich die
bundeswehr jedenfalls hat ihre soldaten
in mali erstmal angewiesen ihre
stützpunkte nicht mehr zu verlassen
tim kröger berichtet es herrscht
relative ruhe in malis hauptstadt bamako
am morgen nach dem plötzlichen umsturz
durch teile des militärs im fernsehen
melden sich erstmals die putschisten zu
wort die alte regierung habe nur chaos
anarchie und unsicherheit gebracht
deswegen sei sie abgesetzt worden
wir laden die zivilgesellschaft und
politische bewegungen ein um die besten
voraussetzungen für einen zivilen
politischen übergang zu schaffen der zu
glaubwürdigen wahlen für gestern
überschlugen sich die ereignisse
zunächst erste putschgerüchte später
wird präsident carter von den soldaten
festgesetzt jubel auf den straßen
wir sind müde das land ist paralysiert
ich will diese regierung nicht mehr
es ist der höhepunkt einer monatelangen
politischen krise in mali mit massiven
protesten die das versagen im kampf
gegen korruption und islamisten
anprangern
in der nacht verkündet der präsident
seinen erzwungenen rücktritt seit dem
touareg und islamisten aufstand 2012
kommt nicht zur ruhe
und das obwohl internationale truppen
darunter rund 900 bundeswehrsoldaten für
mehr sicherheit sorgen sollen
nun wird befürchtet dass die aktuellen
ereignisse den anti-terror-kampf
erschweren und die ganze sache region
weiter destabilisieren könnten wir
stimmen uns sehr ab sehr eng mit unseren
französischen partnern ab um weitere
informationen zur aufklärung der lage zu
erhalten und fordern
zusammen mit vielen anderen staaten die
rückkehr zur verfassungsmäßigen ordnung
die nach unserer einschätzung durch
diesen push push maßgeblich verletzt
worden dass die neue situation habe
vorerst keine auswirkungen auf die
deutschen sicherheitskräfte der
krisenstaat mali aber geht einer
ungewissen zukunft entgegen
der herausforderer von donald trump bei
der us präsidentenwahl im november ist
jetzt offiziell gekürt auf ihrem
virtuellen parteitag hat die
demokratische partei den 77 jahre alten
joe biden als ihren kandidaten nominiert
und zwar mit deutlicher mehrheit
die senatorin kamera harris soll im
falle seines wahlsiegs vize präsidentin
werden ihre offizielle nominierung steht
als nächstes an
wieder zurück nach deutschland die tat
vor gut einem jahr hat entsetzen
ausgelöst ein acht jahre alter junge
wird am frankfurter hauptbahnhof vor
einen fahrenden ic gestoßen und stirbt
seine mutter kann sich in letzter
sekunde retten der mutmaßliche täter
steht seit heute vor gericht wegen einer
schizophrenen erkrankung gilt der 41
jährige beschuldigte aus eritrea als
schuldunfähig
zum prozessauftakt heute sagte der mann
er könne sich an nichts erinnern andrea
meuser die hände gefesselt den blick
gesenkt so betrat hatte er den
verhandlungssaal
dann ließ er seinen verteidiger erklären
seine tat tue ihm unendlich leid
der beschuldigte gilt als schuldunfähig
bestätigt sich dies wird er bei einer
verurteilung dauerhaft in einer
psychiatrischen klinik untergebracht
es könnte sein dass er sich von anderen
verfolgt fühlt und der meinung war er
würde sich beispielsweise gegen eine
gefährdung wären die aber de facto in
der realität gar nicht vorlag
es war der morgen des 29 juli 2009 10
der achtjährige leo wartet mit seiner
mutter im frankfurter hauptbahnhof auf
den ece nach münchen
da stößt der beschuldigte mutter und
sohn auf die gleise
die frau kann sich zur seite rollen ihr
sohn wird von dem zug erfasst und stirbt
noch an der unfallstelle
die eltern wollen nicht nur aufklärung
sie fordern auch verstärkte
niemand kann die kann den kleinen leo
zurückbringen
niemand kann ihnen den wieder geben sie
werden ihr leben lang unter dem verlust
leiden aber sie sagen er soll wenigstens
nicht ganz umsonst gestorben sein
und sie stellen sich natürlich die frage
wie konnte das passieren
wie ist die sicherheit an bahnhöfen
ausgestaltet nach der tat war
angekündigt worden
die videoüberwachung in deutschen
bahnhöfen zu verbessern und 13.000
zusätzliche bundespolizisten einzusetzen
an zwei bahnhöfen haben tests für
zugangsbeschränkungen und absperrungen
an den gleisen begonnen
wann und in welchem umfang solche
maßnahmen umgesetzt werden ist noch
offen
zurzeit gilt 2024 als frühestes datum
dem deutschen wald geht es schlecht und
die schäden sind dramatischer als bisher
angenommen
das belegen neue zahlen des
bundeslandwirtschaftsministeriums
so sind 285 1000 hektar wald verloren
und müssen neu aufgeforstet werden
das ist mehr als die hälfte der fläche
des saarlandes auch die menge an
schadholz hat seit 2008 10 zugenommen
von 160 millionen auf 178 millionen
kubikmeter vor allem schädlinge dürre
und stürme setzen dem wald zu
man muss kein experte sein um das zu
sehen jeden tag jetzt schnitt in der
sendung und damit wir drüben beim sport
und bei dir
christina es gibt kein deutsches finale
in der champions league denn im
halbfinale endete der höhenflug von rb
leipzig 0 zu 3 gegen paris st
zu dominant der französische meister der
dem team von julian nagelsmann in
lissabon eine lehrstunde erteilt eine
deutliche niederlage für julian
nagelsmann zum abschluss einer starken
leipziger champions league saison im
halbfinale zu stehen der champions
league ist eine großartige leistung auf
die man auch stolz sein werden
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen abstand
jetzt aktuell bringt so ein bisschen der
frust glaube das ist auch normal paris
sammer hat ihnen gestern abend mit viel
individueller klasse einfach grenzen
aufgezeigt drei treffer
eine leistung die den deutschen trainer
mit stolz erfüllt wir waren hungrig zu
gewinnen wir waren bereit hart zu
arbeiten das war wirklich eine große
leistung der gesamten mannschaft die
ihren finaleinzug lautstark bejubelte
ein singender nehmer und was machen die
leipziger heute selbstverständlich
drücke ich den bayern die daumen
dann ist eine deutsche mannschaft und
bayern hat uns auch die daumen gedrückt
zum anpfiff des zweiten halbfinales
sollten sie aus lissabon zurück sein
ja und mit dem zehnten sieg nacheinander
wollen die bayern ins finale der
rekordmeister ohne personalsorgen aber
wohl wissen dass das gegen olympique
lyon kein selbstläufer wird trainer
hansi flick bringt sein team in stellung
und die spieler bringen sich in angriff
stimmung jetzt nur nicht abheben denn
die erwartungen sind nach dem 82
glanzauftritt gegen barcelona riesig
doch im halbfinale gegen olympique lyon
geht es wieder von null los die
franzosen zu unterschätzen wäre fatal
haben sie mit juventus turin und
manchester city doch zwei favoriten aus
dem wettbewerb gekickt ich bin relaxed
was das ganze angeht weil ich einfach
weiß dass die mannschaft das sehr
fokussiert ist dass sie große ziele hat
torjäger lewandowski kratzt schon jetzt
mit 14 champions-league-treffern am
ronaldo rekord von 17 toren oder auch
thomas müller steht für die neue
harmonische bayern power trainer flick
hat auf seinen stars ein verschworenes
team geformt das mit 27 siegen in den
letzten 28 pflichtspielen unschlagbar
erscheint 21 uhr ist anpfiff claudia
neumann ist in lissabon was hört man
denn so von den bayern ja so gut wie gar
nichts und das ist ein sehr gutes
zeichen alle möglichen startelf
kandidaten sind fit selbstvertrauen
konzentration und respekt vorm gegner
scheint in optimalen verhältnis zu
stehen bei den bayern
es spricht vieles für den deutschen
rekordmeister der mit neun siegen in
dieser champions-league-saison
durchmarschiert ist und auch das estadio
jose alvalade wo beide mannschaften
minütlich erwartet werden da weckt gute
erinnerungen zwei mal sind die bayern
hier in der vergangenheit angetreten
gegen sporting beide spiele wurden
gewonnen
vielen dank claudia neumann nach
lissabon und wenn es die bayern schaffen
gibt es das finale sonntagabend vier
live bei uns im zdf
herding absolut sodann habe ich hier
noch irgendwo die lottozahlen da sind
sie die gewinnzahlen lauten 5 18 22 27
38 48 die superzahl 1 und weitere
gewinnzahl finden sie wie immer auf
lotto zdf de und dem zdf text auf seite
55 7
im vergleich zu den letzten unwetter
tagen wird das morgen eher ruhig sonne
wolken wenig regen eigentlich ganz
schöne details gleich von katja
horneffer 21 uhr 45 ist zeit für
marietta slomka wir alle vom team der
heute 19 danken für ihr interesse gerne
bis morgen aber erst in allen 1
angegeben haben
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren ist das
jetzt hier spätsommer oder schon früh
herbst ja es bildet sich nach so langen
nächten durchaus schon nebel oder dunst
wie hier heute morgen in der eifel
jedenfalls dann eines vorher geregnet
hat und dann auf klagte und das ist eine
klare nacht gaben lag an dem hoch
frederik das zusammen mit dem tiefen
trauer über dem atlantik die warme luft
aus richtung iberische halbinsel und
frankreich bis zu uns treibt und dass es
wärmer wird merken wir schon in dieser
nacht denn die temperaturen sinken im
westen nicht unter 9 10 bis 16 grad im
osten wird es dagegen bei 16 bis 11 grad
kühler
denn dort ist der himmel klar im westen
dagegen sind diese wolken angekommen und
die bringen in der nacht dann auch regen
mit und dieser regen erreicht dann
morgen die nordseeküste etwa südlich der
nördlichen mittelgebirge scheint die
sonne zum teil strahlen hier zwischen
dem alpenrand und der mosel und es wird
wieder heiß
die temperaturen klettern morgen auf 27
bis 34 grad und einzig entlang der
küsten von nord- und ostsee und in
schleswig holstein werden es so 24 bis
26 grad
am freitag wird es mit 37 grad noch
heißer dann kommt eine kaltfront und so
liegen die temperaturen am sonntag nur
noch bei 20 bis 25 grad schönen abend
noch